all right Monica yes Monica you you work
for a firm that helps out a lot of the
people that I interview right I do I
work for Patrick Katie foundation
exactly so we find people 25 and under
that are in need of support in getting
off of drugs getting off the street
we sponsor them we get them through
detox residential sober living
vocational training we get them back
into school if they want it throughout
the recovery process people kind of move
through a lot of things they want to do
so we work with them until they get
solid on what they see for themselves
and then we go there that's great so
some of the people that my viewers
respond to like Christina and Maddie and
for the young younger people would be
prime candidates for what you guys do
right they would be wonderful candidates
I want to help them yeah yeah that's
great and then you know the donation
campaign that I they go fund me campaign
that I started recently which a portion
is designed to like help some of these
people hmm so so far I think we're at
around $20,000 which is which is nice
but I'm I'm concerned that maybe that's
just not gonna solve these people's
problems especially if we're spreading
this 20,000 over 20 people or more yeah
that buys Maddie a new tent and
Christine has some clothes and a tent
and you know stuff like that
it doesn't really solve their it doesn't
change the direction of their lives
it doesn't just to give context putting
someone through detox is five hundred
and fifty dollars a day on average in
California so that's just the 7 to 10
days to get them off what they're on
that's not the residential which keeps
them off and starts to do therapy and
that kind of stuff so when you do the
math it costs without insurance 35 to 40
grand to get somebody clean and sober
and safe for a solid amount of time and
you have to think most people are gonna
have hiccups so they got to go back to
detox it's very rare that we get
somebody into detox and they don't use
again so it adds up really fast and even
with insurance sometimes things are
covered but it's it's short stays it's
it's not the full distance that someone
has to go to get clean and stay clean by
any stretch of the imagination I have a
lot of subscribers or viewers to my
channel and if everybody that watched my
channel donated the minimum amount we
could do everything you're describing it
more for everybody really but but I
don't know if that's really in the cards
so that'd be great but it seems like a
lot of people I help don't really have
what it takes to to help and a lot of
people a lot of my donors to this
campaign have been amazing there's some
people that donated I think twenty five
hundred dollars one person did a few had
a thousand and a lot of 500 things like
that that's amazing
yeah very grateful its donors but but we
still don't have a million people
donating the minimum which would really
make a huge difference right that's
that's what it takes and and listen I
mean with the donations you have you can
get feminine products you can get tents
we can go get mass amounts of food and
feed people but if it were that easy if
it took a thousand bucks to get somebody
off the streets and off drugs well most
people wouldn't be in the position
they're in because think about some of
the women that you're interviewing how
much money they can make in a day if it
were that easy they wouldn't be in this
position yeah so you guys have been
around for how long how many years four
years now four years mhm
and your base right down the street from
me right off the basically you're in
right in the edge of Skid Row yeah yeah
and so tell me I mean so you're a
non-profit yes and you can only handle
so many people at once it's not you have
400 people that you're fixing right yeah
yeah well how many people typically do
you take anything well it just depends
on my personal capacity as well as the
shays and Jim's because we're really
small right now the less people we hire
the less people we have to pay the more
people we can help but you have to think
when you're spending that much time you
know you spend a lot of time with these
people and they have your cell phone
number it's taxing
and worth it but still taxing to be of
support in the way that these people
need cuz a lot of these people have
never had anyone care about them so the
journey is exhausting for both the
person going through recovery and the
person assisting them in that so the
caseworker aspect of it so if we can get
more funding and I can bring in more
people that can work with people through
their journeys I mean the sky's the
limit but again you have to pay somebody
more often than not to be willing to
work full-time and help these people but
I can take two to three people a year
right now because it takes about a year
to get somebody through the process so
how do you - aside from the people that
I interview I mean how would you find
someone and how would they sign up for
your program and how would they pay for
it well we have a website with an
application on it then - a help set up
in terms of paying for it it doesn't
cost them anything the whole point of
what we're doing is is helping people
who can't pay for this kind of stuff
themselves so it's really just as simple
as going on the website filling out an
application being super authentic on
your application because you got to be
ready for recovery you got to want it
you got to be done one thing in the list
of things needed right yeah yeah and a
lot of people say they want it but they
can't follow and and when they're coming
down from their high or whatever they do
want it they mean what they're saying
but they have to want it 24 hours a day
seven days a week because when you stop
using all of the demons all the memories
everything comes rushing back and that's
so overwhelming and then you're in a
place where you don't really know
anybody and the only person you have is
me or in a chez or Jim and we're on the
outside so we're there for you but you
know we can't hold you when you're
sleeping so it's intimidating and that's
why a lot of people go back to it
because it's it's really scary people
typically use drugs because they're
trying to escape something really
painful the broken childhood is the the
beginning of it all right I mean most of
people on your channel most everyone
I've worked with
and a terrible childhood that's why the
first question I ask is basically tell
me about your job right exactly
and if he have you had success stories
yes yeah one of my most recent graduates
Manu is now in school for music
production it took a while he had a
number of relapses but we stuck with him
he's been sober for about a year now he
actually wants to come back and work for
the foundation when he's done with
school which is really cool
that's my most recent yeah that's great
we have others but yeah and it's I mean
I think a lot of viewers will make a
comment oh just go to rehab and
everything's fine but what I've seen and
I'm sure you've seen it it's the same as
I have because I've been doing this for
a long time there's so many other
factors that are just not working in
these individuals I mean they don't they
don't understand how to trust others
they don't understand how to communicate
sometimes they don't understand how to
handle money they don't understand no
they don't they get money in their
pocket that means they get to spend it
right they don't know saving that none
of them have bank accounts or driver's
licenses or write or they don't know how
to be responsible they haven't been
responsible for ever what example had
they had most of the time so it's it's
it's a long it's a it's such a and
that's again why it's you have to really
want recovery because it is a beast like
you know manure his license was expired
his passports expired he doesn't have
this he doesn't have that I had to go to
the college because they wouldn't admit
him because of his record I had to go to
the college of petition with the board
to get him into the school it's a lot of
work it's a lot of work to get out of
and he has a good family but it's still
a lot of work to get out of to get out
of it and then you have to think about -
there's a lot going on in the recovery
community that's questionable so like my
foundation we vet the detox and
residential and sober living places that
we're sending our clients to and we have
to because so much of the recovery game
is bodies and beds so even if someone go
and off the street just goes I'm gonna
go to this detox center I'm gonna try it
what's the likelihood that there aren't
drugs in the facility that people aren't
taking advantage of people in the
facility it's slim I mean let's say I
wanted to take a portion of the
donations that have come in and this go
fund me on my channel and give it to you
guys and maybe you guys could maybe if
Cristina's on board we could take 15
over there and maybe you guys could help
her if she's only you know if that all
works for her huh that that could
potentially help her tremendously right
yes what would you do you would so high
school well we need to work on the GED
first we have to make sure she's sober
so that's step number one
this the other thing that kind of has to
happen at the same time for her is
clarity on her parental situation
because she is underage so we have to
find an attorney that's willing to take
her case to make sure that we're doing
all the stuff we're doing properly so
that we don't put ourselves or you or
her in any type of dangerous situation
or a comfortable situation and then
after she's clean then we go to GED then
we go from there what does she want what
does life look like now that you
understand that you are cared for and
you do have possibilities might be some
job training or something like that
whatever she wants I'll make it happen
that's wonderful
yeah that's great yeah so I mean no now
maybe viewers can understand why a
robust support of a thing like this can
do a lot of good but other than that
it'll be like we helped Christina and
then everyone else is left high and dry
when I think we have the potential to
help a lot of people yes they you see on
my channel mm-hmm
there's others coming up and there's
some in the past Maddie a bunch of
others that could really benefit but you
can only handle so much and and and as
you see with lawyers with with housing
with everything it gets very expensive
it does get very expensive and then
there's also the final aspect which we
spoke about the other day which is the
mental health aspect because some of
these people have undiagnosed
misdiagnosed correctly diagnosed
situations that are
very challenging if someone's that has
schizophrenia there's an even more
there's another layer that that's
compounded on so people I've seen
comments like you know 5150 then well
that that's a 72-hour hold
and our system's gonna put them back
into the world so this won't do a 5150
if they do it at all yeah I couldn't
count how many 5150 comments that were
on Amanda's last video it's like the
police have been approached 50 times
about doing a 5150 on Amanda and they
they just watch as we're learning
there's a lot of corruption and a lot of
elements of our judicial system and that
leads down into LAPD and everywhere else
silence go back as the sirens go by my
experience with the LAPD has been great
yeah I appreciate what they've done yeah
for me right they've saved my ass a few
times so I have no problems with the
police but but I understand that it's
just difficult job and they can't like
it's such an overwhelming environment
here in Skid Row and in any other place
like this that unfortunately this is
last on the totem pole so if if someone
does get 51:58 again they're released
after 72 hours the likelihood that they
send them to a facility in which case
that's still only 14 days and then
they're still sent back out it's it's
it's a huge conversation just back me up
on this one you know Amanda you're
familiar yeah tell me there are not
three hundred other Amanda's out here I
mean I live and work right here and I
feed a lot of the people that live at
the back of my street and a lot of a lot
of people here are battling mental
health issues because on the way in this
morning like that would be a great male
version of them right there right Amanda
and there's they're everywhere
everywhere people because where do they
go where do they go they're either in
the jail system or they're here if they
don't have the means to go handle it
well what you guys do is it sounds great
sounds amazing yeah I enjoy doing it see
if we can get one of these young people
that we that I've interviewed to maybe
sign up or try to get into it yeah see
what goes so the campaign I've got going
so far it may not be as robust as it
could be but it's still very helpful I
mean a lot of the people that are over
25 that you guys don't really deal with
still could benefit that's the majority
of the people I interview anyway I mean
Latoya I can get it maybe we can get her
a hotel room for a week or maybe we can
get Caroline off the street for a while
or get it some so-and-so a new tent or
you know there's so many people that
come to me looking for clothes or
looking for shoes or there's money for
food so so the donations are still
useful even even with you know it's it's
a few hundred dollars a day that are
coming in now that that's still very
helpful
because that'll that'll make it a lot of
these people that you see on my channel
you know it'll make their lives more
comfortable more pleasant and I'm sure
they'll appreciate that as I do because
otherwise it comes out of my pocket
entirely but but I think and then maybe
who knows maybe some miracle will happen
and we'll get more supportive this
campaign I'm not big on promoting it so
this is so that's part of the problem
but I have a hard time telling people to
hit the subscribe button please
subscribe don't don't forget it don't
forget to donate this is important work
it's not my personality this is
important work this is a really big
problem that this country has and we
have the opportunity that for the first
time that I've seen on a large scale
with what you've already got going on
she'll bring awareness or a period of
time to bring awareness to the human
beings that are that are really hurting
and that we we really have not set them
up to win but we have an opportunity to
shift that
so let's [ __ ] shift it awesome
Veronica thank you so much for coming in
no problem I look forward to work with
you me too Thanks
you